let's talk a little bit about the impact
of coronavirus on kind of corporate debt
situation that writes a great question
so one of the things that I saw in China
I was reading that these Chinese
companies are levered to the [ __ ]
head with all this debt if there's an
economic slowdown even a little stalling
of the economy all of a sudden they
can't pay the debt you have to have the
government a bank somebody has to step
in there's all kinds of ramifications
how do you look at that let start in the
US and then maybe cool look so step back
from a macro perspective define the
bubble that the biggest part of the
bubble that were in now it's the
corporate debt bubble okay there is a
mechanism behind that that is very
important to people to understand so
where does this debt come from comes
from American companies issuing their
what are they issuing debt they issuing
debt to buy back their own shares it's
an accounting trick and to make it worse
they're issuing selves the management
team stock options then they at the at
the board they then say right and how
many shares should we bite back today
guess what if you're removing the number
of shares your share price goes up in
normal circumstances so they're making
themselves rich by basically raping the
shareholders the shareholders have an
optical illusion because the price is
going up but actually all these
corporations taking more and more debt
iBM has been a classic example of that
so that's that mechanism of where the
debt comes from
now the buyer of that debt is the
pension system because there's bunch of
these poor baby boomers getting close to
retirement it don't have enough savings
so they look for any yield they can so
corporate debt has a bit more yield than
government bonds and it's deemed safe so
we'll just buy as much of that as you
can give us and that is being driven by
all these pensions didn't have enough
returns over the last 4050 years so they
the states these state pensions the
states have raised taxes and are putting
the tax money into these pensions and
that tax money is it comes in every
month other people's wages buys these
corporate bonds so you got this lovely
environment where these 1% are getting
extremely rich the corporations are
issuing more and more debt and buying
back their shares they are the only
buyer of equities if you look on
aggregate almost everybody else is a net
divestiture of equities in the world
there's a bit of foreign buying that's
it the entire pension system is trying
to divest of equities but it's still
switching to credit but as every baby
boomer leaves the workforce that
eventually starts yet moving out so the
entire worlds and net seller of equities
but the corporations are the buyers and
we just had one of the biggest stock
market bubbles of all time then on the
other side we've had the biggest credit
bubble of all time corporations are now
because of this ridiculous tax rule are
now Cobra debts GDP the house has ever
been in history and the issue is is
there is only one bar of that credit
which is a pension system really because
even we yields are too low for half of
insurance companies up but let's say
it's insurance companies and these
pension companies when you go into
recession or just the business cycle
goes negative just a normal one forget
that depression scenario just a normal
recession there's a company your cash
flows go negative and your earnings go
negative right it's standard pretty
obvious yeah
well that means you stopped buying back
your shares because you don't have the
cash flow to buy your shares so that
means that the moment you go into
recession which is where we're going now
just when you need it the most
in illiquid markets the world's largest
part of equities leaves and there are no
baby boomers buying equities
there's no Millennials buying it there's
nobody to offset this would it be fair
to say there that the structure you just
don't know let me finish the other side
of the structure the other side of the
structure is tax receipts are driven by
the business cycle so when taxes REITs
go negative when the business cycle goes
negative and therefore there's no buying
in these state pensions of the corporate
debt either so what you have is at the
very same time as soon as the business
cycle goes negative give it a you know a
month or two of lag basically the bar of
credit leaves the bar of equity leaves
and there's no buyers at the same time
you have this huge amount of these
triple B credits which are huge old
companies that have issued so much debt
that they've been downgraded and
downgraded that could get knocked into
junk if they get not into junk status
they will leave these credit portfolios
and have to go and jump pump up for this
problem this is four trillion of these
bonds so the numbers are too big for the
junk bond market to absorb so the jump
up jump bond market will just basically
seize up and to accommodate it yields
will have to explode
when there's no buyer I need to get that
across there is no buyer of this stuff
and there is no viral vector which means
that the share price of General Electric
Ford and all of it these triple B's get
pummeled which increases the chance of a
downgrade which increases the chance of
them dipping so what you've got I call
it the Doom loop and I feel like we're
just about to set that off and credit is
the next big thing so this structure
that you just described how we've kind
of gotten here there's two key
components to it the first is the 1% got
really really rich during this run we
have seen an explosion of CEOs and
c-suite executives walking through the
door they're leaving yeah and they're
not leaving because they think it's
gonna get a better situation they've
kind of made a lot of money and now
seems to be a good time even to the
point of seeing somebody like a Bolliger
do it overnight effective immediately
right this isn't a hey I'm going to
leave in six months or in a year this is
I was gonna leave you know in a year or
two now I'm leaving today is that what
it looks like is it that these
executives understand kind of the
situation you're describing and it's
always better to leave at the top kind
of walk out with the championship trophy
then then wait till it's a bad situation
yes and I was just talking to a friend
of mine last night it's just sold his
business has been investment banking
business
he's just sold it now why is he held on
for ten years why does he just sell it
now another friend of mine sold his
audio-visual business why now and it's
because they kind of know time now's a
good time look we all think we can't and
we can't but these guys kind of know
that particularly at that level of
c-suite and because it's overrun by baby
boomers so let's assume that most of
these people are 65 to 70 or 60 to 70
that's the cohort of the c-suite of
corporate America well you're about to
go into retirement you just don't want
to deal with this
mm-hmm and because really there's an 18
24 month period let's say that's a
recession or a depression right it's
really really bad for most people and
then you'll get a recovery somehow we've
seen in other situations but that
recovery just to get back to the same
level you work could take years if not
well it doesn't work if you're a retiree
so it's different if you're young if
you're young it's like okay this is
going to be one of the war stories that
you will have like I have them come on a
podcast in 20 years time with the war
stories right that's fine but and you're
there are opportunities they'll be
opportunity to make money I think
there's a whole new financial system
coming out this and we'll get into that
later but for the baby boomers the
problem is is they can't buy the dip
because they're retiring so you're going
to let's say the average recession not
really bad when an average recession
lowers share prices by about 40 percent
maybe 50
well you're incentivized to sell because
you want to crystallize your losses and
I've seen this firsthand from friends of
mine and parents 2001-2008 the thing is
oshit protect my pool I will just make
the wrong decision but I have to sell I
cannot see my money go down even less
because then I'm going to run out and be
bankrupt when I'm old if I'm bankrupt
that's at 80 years old and totally
[ __ ] so they're incentivized
behavioral incentive is I have to sell
so that is inherently built into the
system the pension system is implicitly
a short a put as well because they have
to deliver returns through retirees now
the problem is is then if they've
allocated too much to equity and they're
gonna have to pay entitlements these
people in two years time well somehow
they don't have to sell that equity to
pay that entire time and the more yields
fall I mean let me talk about this yet
but this yield fall from two percent to
one percent basically means you need
twice as much money to live off the
yield as it goes to zero you can never
have enough money to live off yield so
you have to eat to have capital gains
that completely screws up all pension
calculations does this lead to the blow
up do we see pensions blow up in major
ways listen I've been talking about this
for a long
everybody's gonna have to understand the
reality that their pension is not what
they think it is what does that mean
know what I mean that weddings now what
it they think it is is that they your
ink it's a promise okay and a guarantee
what it's not what it it is not that
okay you will not get even if you're a
fireman or a teacher
or somebody's worked all their life and
you've been told you'll get 2/3 of your
final salary that will not happen you
may be lucky and be one of the first one
few your benefits may get cut later
we've seen it everywhere happened the
same so that promise is not real so your
dreams of retirement not our dreams in
terms of what you think and nobody's got
enough the other reality is is nobody
has enough to retire on it's the numbers
will not work unless you're one of the
1% because the if you look at the
average not the average the median baby
boomer because the average is so skewed
by the ultra-rich if you look at the
median baby boomer they've got like
$200,000 I mean they're basically we can
leave the last five years what does that
mean poor so this is why I'm
particularly worried about this
confluence of events so going to the
recession fine then the coronavirus no
sorry let's go back going through a
session fine you've always got the
kindling of this debt issue the massive
corporate debt bubble you've got an
equity market bubble okay we can kind of
deal with that but that's like 2008 and
2001 it's kind of a hybrid when you put
the coronavirus on top and you
accelerate at all and then you've got
the pension issues with no pensioners
being able to afford to retire and think
what that does to GDP coming out of a
recession it never recovers and nor does
the stock market because there's no bar
so we go into a very different world now
can we
again extrapolate more concerning events
to the financial system and the end of
this you know how to insurance company
survive the medical insurance stuff had
an app what happens and the point being
is in part of this there's another story
that there's a story that I've talked
about a lot is the shortage of dollars
in the world and in this situation that
could become a problem as well